[Musique]
bonsoir que tes amis que je suis
impatient ce soir patron impatient
d'annoncer à pimprenelle et nicolas la
grande nouvelle
et oui nounours c'est d'accord qui peut
descendre leur dire nous les emmèneront
en voyage sur notre nuage tout est prévu
alors à tout de suite pas trop chauffer
il est jeune au pro bowl
[Musique]
bonsoir
mais vous sont-ils dans la salle
[Musique]
gokana tu vas être sage attrayant tout
je pense que parce qu'anna il en a fait
des os longs taux de leurs trois jaunes
qui s'appelait tôt voire à la salle de
bain ces beignets et il a peut-être ses
mains tout une ondée oui aussi on l'a
remis dans son panier ça y'a pas de là
haut le coco loco code aucoin quoi
tu l'as fait peur avec ta concevoir au
long le pas peur kana on va tous chanté
une chanson
lui coûtent bien
[Musique]
quand je passais par le bois le coucou
chante
et dans son joli chant faisait coucou
coucou coucou
et moi je croyais qu'il disait au puy le
coucou puis le coup et moi du coup je
m'en sens veut sauf aimerait du coup
j'ai en sauveur
il
quand je passais par le pré le faucheur
proches
aidants sont jolis chants faisaient là
quelle chaleur à quelle chaleur salaires
ags un chalet et moi je croyais qu'ils
disaient en quelle valeur à quel voleur
et moi du coup le manceau un sombre et
moi du coup je mange rover
[Musique]
et
quand je passais près de l'aidant canard
à la jambe en clair
dans son jolie chanteuse et moi
et moi je croyais qu'ils disaient qu'ils
aillent au moins ils aillent au point et
moi du coup je mens son voeu sombre et
moi du coup je pense aux bains
[Musique]
oui alors tu écoutes on dit contact
with
un coin moins
[Rires]
amère oui parce que j'ai une grande
nouvelle à vous annoncer
nos vies au lude amant
lui qu'un or
l'armée nous
nous sommes couchés demain je vous
emmène en voyage
sur notre nuage
jusque chez notre ami cornichons
[Musique]
oui il a tout prévu
tu n'as pas vouloir s' est d'accord on
lui a téléphoné
ne vous énervez pas en dormez-vous vite
demain nous voyagerons
ni bonne nuit les petits
la j'éteins la lumière
at home
[Musique]
en patron si vous avez vu leur joie le
cher petit toi aussi tu es content nous
n'aurons oui j'aime tellement faire
plaisir aux enfants en route mon bon
nounours bonne eu des enfants n'oubliez
pas de faire votre toilette de bien vous
laver les dents allez vite vous coucher
et feu de bois
[Musique]
o o
oh
où
oui